on va aller se balancer je pense parce
que c'est ce que je vois elle aime le
plus se balancer Marie-Claude Sénégal et
ça fait Johany sont comblés par les
installations du parc Saint-Joseph et si
c'est vraiment le plus beau jamais seul
contrairement à d'autres il n'y a
personne pour pouvoir sortir la personne
qui
s'en souvient très bien
vous en rappelez longtemps c'est
vraiment issus de cette mobilisation de
ce cri du cœur en plus d'avoir répondu à
cette demande les responsables du projet
en consulter les bénéficiaires avant de
procéder ils ont demandé
qu'elle s'en vont vous attends en quels
sont vos besoins de quoi vous auriez
envie autant pour les non-voyants que
pour les lourdement handicapé les 1111
cafés qu'ils ont fait une surface qui
s'adapte
le parc Saint-Joseph a donc été aménagé
selon les principes de l'accessibilité
universelle
qui
est de plus en plus nombreux en 2013 33
% des Québécois déclaré
donc c'est quand même une très
importante de la population
le vieillissement de la population y est
pour quelque chose aussi et un autre que
beaucoup aidée c'est qu'on se rend
compte que la commode les gens qui ont
des problèmes
des aménagements qui sont dans le
profitable pour l'ensemble de la
population en grand à tout pour les
familles selon Marie-Claude aucun par un
peu je m'en vais au parc avec mes
enfants et tous mes enfants il y a que
mon enfant de cape et que s'amuser c'est
ce qu'on veut
vraiment
Radio-Canada Montréal